we're gonna have a game against btk
too
[Music]
it's probably the chest style of my
opponent
bind torture collapse
oh collapses with a c
yeah it doesn't work then we're going to
triangle for the so-called kasparov
gambit
which occurs after
it would have occurred after um knight
p5 d5
after knight b3 will go
night hunting instead
a4 and now we go for d5
queen d5 to come and we claim that
the knight on d3 is quite vulnerable
because of the inclusion of a5 a4
and also the b4 square is looking mighty
juicy for my pieces
now we just exchange 95 to come
and although the position is quite
symmetrical it seems
to me that it's it's considerably better
for black
knight d2 logical we go knight c6
and i think we got knight before
maybe this has been all wrong
castles now
i castle knight c4
maybe this is just insane
[Music]
oh this is a bad mistake
this is a really really really bad
mistake positionally speaking
so 94 there was very interesting
attacking a5 twice
so what happens now is that
my opponent's knights are in a complete
bind
rook d3 is is a is a threat
immediately winning one of the knights
and the knight in b3 simply has nowhere
to go it's abstract obstructed by my
pieces
but mainly by its own
and my opponent gave away the bishop
which was really important in securing
a hold over the light squares and
without that hold
my bishop on e6 rules the game
and concretely
it's going to be hard to avoid the loss
of of a piece
so this is this is yeah this is really
an interactive mistake by my opponent
so i could go rook d3 when a piece but i
just want to
underline how helpless my opponent's
position
is by by not taking the piece for
a little bit
g3 yeah well i'll just take the piece
why not that was the rook d3 was anyway
the last
the last the next logical move in the
sequence
and it just so happens that it wins
wednesday night
f4 was the only chance there instead
now i just collect
fp595 protecting f7
and no worries
bishop g5 we just go f6
8 not in d3 is very strong so i don't
want to exchange it off for the bishop
quite yet
and it's yeah it's also was obstructing
the rook from coming to c1
which i think was an important factor
rook d3 that's a sack of an exchange but
unfortunately
it's in like it's a it is it's an
exciting exchange sec
for only one check
bishop goes back we go g5
rook c7 king d8 bishop cannot protect
rook anymore so he loses the bishop
and my opponent resides yeah so i was
critical of my opponent's opening play
in this game but i think
probably overly critical and
really the only huge mistake my opponent
made was bishop take c6 and move
13 which i think essentially just gave
the game away
yes